[Music]
oh welcome back to cbs mornings work
work work and that's what we're talking
about or lack thereof the united states
has had a shortage of workers this year
leaving businesses struggling to find
new employees some of them are using an
app called insta work to deal with that
problem this is how it works insta work
connects businesses with people who are
willing to work day to day as needed as
carter evans reports some of the
customers say this app is a godsend
during the pandemic and especially
during the holidays
so this is one of our most popular gifts
and lula's garden in los angeles tis the
season for
succulents but ceo loras birnbaum says
getting holiday help during the pandemic
worker shortage is a challenge have you
hired any people that haven't shown up
and things like that definitely
so instead of placing a want ad she
orders insta workers on an app
and you have a worker show up the next
morning workers show up the next morning
do you have to send them a paycheck no
that's the best part once you put the
credit card on the app it's just charged
automatically every worker has a
schedule right that meets their needs
and that schedule can change from week
to week samir magani co-founded insta
work in 2016. what makes this different
from say a temp agency where
economic opportunity at the touch of a
button
a worker can create a profile get to
work within a day and when covet hit
last year business took off the whole
workforce changed how they work during
the pandemic they're not just looking
for better jobs or higher pay they're
looking for more flexible work that
appealed to chester lemon who lost his
job during the pandemic now he has a
selection of shifts and pay now i can
comfortably say i am my own boss how
does that feel it's a good feeling
one day he's working at a clothing
designer warehouse and the next he's
working at concert i did bts this past
weekend and the best part for him
getting paid immediately so let me get
this straight when you go home today the
money from this job will be in your bank
account before i get to my car with more
than one and a half million workers in
25 u.s cities the company can also
provide real-time economic insight just
since april of this year wages on the
app are up an average of 20 percent
we found that about half of our
professionals aren't willing to work for
less than fifteen dollars an hour that's
more than double the federal minimum
wage the company charges employers a
commission but workers pay nothing and
what would you say to critics who say
insta work is just another middleman
that adds cost what i would say is that
our workers speak with their swipe like
most insta workers chester lemon is an
independent contractor with no benefits
or overtime do you ever see yourself
having a regular nine to five job again
at one place it's gonna be hard right
now because i've gotten so
used to this now when you know you can
just make money tonight tomorrow
anytime you feel like it for now the job
flexibility is priceless i've had
numerous job offers from companies that
i've worked with
numerous but you turned them down yep
how did it feel to be able to say no oh
it feels very good
for cbs mornings i'm carter evans in los
angeles
i think it's great yeah it's cool that's
the big part of it right though is that
you get to pick the hours you get to
pick the job you get to pick where
you're going we've talked about this
before the pandemic will really sort of
realign how people work how people live
and there will be some positives that
come of it this is one of them well it's
not only that but if you think about the
pandemic child care has been up in the
air for so many people so maybe maybe
you work one week but your child's in
quarantine the next week so you kind of
have to pick and choose the job
sometimes too so it works as somewhat of
a temp agency but like you said it
allows the individual to be their own
boss yeah i think that's since working
at a bts concert i mean
that's it that's pretty cool i'm working
a restaurant later
sign me up